so with the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
completed I thought it would be fun to
do something a little bit different here
and so what we're gonna be doing is
we're gonna be making the list
specifically we're gonna be outlining
what I consider to be the top five most
powerful characters in Marvel Comics
that originate from the planet Earth
meaning we're not going to be using
characters like fan O's with the heart
of the universe or The Living Tribunal
or the one above all this list is
specifically going to be confined to
superheroes and supervillains that
originate from the planet Earth in
Marvel Comics so the first person on our
list is Franklin Richards and I'm really
hoping that this this first introduction
this character this Frank is number five
will give you some idea of the direction
we're going in terms of the overall
power of earthbound characters that
we're going to be going with some very
powerful individuals but the reason why
I chose to rank Franklin Richards as
number five is for a couple reasons the
first reason here is because of course
Franklin Richards for the majority of
his appearances in Marvel Comics is a
child and it's hinted at that he has
incredible power it's hinted at that he
could be one of the most powerful
characters within the Marvel Comics
that's an Earthbound character but for
the most part we don't really see this
playing out that often the most notable
instance that we saw was of course
something we had talked about during our
video about Franklin Richards when we
had talked about avatar
but aside from this it's actually not
until the Future foundation when we see
the adult version of Franklin Richards
that we see the kind of power that he
possesses but even then it requires both
the power of the adult Franklin Richards
as well as the power that his child
version had been saving up over the
course of his life for Franklin Richards
to make Galactus his Herald now in later
stories of the Fantastic Four we see
that Franklin Richards approaches
godhood due to the amount of power he
possesses but again it's not until much
later on that we see those abilities
it's not during his initial introduction
more comics that we see these kind of
powers again it's when he's an adult so
the next person on our list is mad Jim
Jasper's and the reason why I chose to
list mad Jim Jasper's is number four and
Franklin Richards number five is because
to me mad Jim Jasper's has been
demonstrated to us as being far more
powerful than Franklin Richards now
while the debate reigns and the debate
is very contested in terms of who is
more powerful whether it be imagine
Jasper's or Franklin Richards the fact
remains that we can only really go by
the information that's been given to us
in the comics and anything that hasn't
been mentioned in the comics is simply
just non-canon and is subject to
speculation and so what we see with Mad
Jim Jasper is is that he first appears
and Marvel superheroes issue number 377
and a story called the crooked worlds
storyline and what we learn is that
Captain Britain has been sent to the
Marvel to 380 universe to confront mad
Jim Jasper's on the planet Earth in this
alternate reality and what we had
learned over the course of this story is
that Mad Jim Jasper's had done two
things the first thing he had done is he
created a being called the fury and the
fury was designed to uh not only
eliminate all earthbound superheroes in
this reality but was also designed to be
able to adapt to any attack that was
imposed upon it and so during this
storyline imagine Jasper's initiate
something called the Jasper's warp and
it's exactly what it sounds like
the Jasper's warp emanates from Mad Jim
Jasper's himself and begins to warp that
reality in such a degree that it becomes
a threat to the other realities around
it and so the dimensional development
court the group that oversees the
evolution of various realities to ensure
that they are maintaining the the s
forward evolution with regards to
super-powered beings and so on had
decided to eliminate the entire earth
two three eight universe which also
resulted in the destruction of that
universes version of Mad Jim Jasper's
what we also learn over the course of
this story is that the reason Captain
Britain had been sent to the earth two
three eight universe was so not
necessarily so that he could defeat that
universe
version of Mad Jim Jasper's but so that
he could be prepared for the conflict
that would come when he came into
contact with the earth-616 version of
Mad Jim Jasper's who was far more
powerful than his earth 238 counterpart
and what we learn is that the theory had
actually survived the destruction of the
earth two three eight universe and upon
realizing that captain Britain was
within the earth-616 dimension had
teleported himself to this reality but
when the fury came to the earth-616
universe it had realized that Matt Jim
Jasper's was here but that it was not
the same mad Jim jaws pers that had
created him and so he was free to
destroy or attempt to destroy this
version of Jasper's and this is where
their power the real power of mad Jim
Jasper's comes into play when we see
that during the conflict between himself
and the fury he begins warping reality
arbitrarily begins changing everything
entirely and what the fury learns here
is that in order for mad Jim Jasper's to
manipulate reality he has to have a
reality to manipulate that he can't
simply create something out of nothing
and so what he does is he teleports mad
Jim Jasper's to the void that was
formerly the earth to 3/8 universe where
madam - pers is now powerless because he
has no reality to manipulate and because
he's powerless the fury takes this time
to destroy him so I think that quite
possibly the most contested person on
this list will be apocalypse and the
reason why is because I think people
will look at characters like mad Jim
Jasper's or characters like Franklin
Richards and say look at the kind of
power they possess how is it possible
that a character like apocalypse could
possibly go toe-to-toe with them well
the reason why I chose apocalypse for
number three is for two reasons one
because of the incredible power that he
possesses due to the fact that he can
manipulate his own physiology he can
shape-shift he can do any number of
things but he has total control over his
atomic structure but also because of his
intellect in terms of what it is that he
knows and how intelligent he is there is
virtually no one that rivals him the
only individuals that come remotely
close to
his intelligence are dr. doom and Reed
Richards now again these are earthbound
characters there are individuals out
within the Marvel Universe that are
clearly as smart as he is if not more
powerful especially when you look at
someone like fan OHS but when you look
at the history of apocalypse in Marvel
Comics for the most part it's been
relatively consistent that his character
has simply just been kept at bay
in addition apocalypse has demonstrated
the ability to overpower characters like
The Incredible Hulk demonstrating that
he has an incredible amount of physical
strength so I think the Vulcan will
proved to be one of the more
controversial entries in this list of
our top five most powerful characters in
Marvel Comics and I think the reason why
it'll be controversial is for two
reasons the first is because not a lot
of people know who Vulcan is and this is
rightful in the sense that Vulcan didn't
show up until 2006 and x-men deadly
Genesis issue number one
and in fact in much the same ways the
centuries introduction Marvel had
introduced Vulcan in such a way to where
they and more or less said that he had
been part of the x-men for quite some
time where was an older member of the
x-men team who had helped to rescue the
original x-men but he had disappeared
from the Marvel landscape for a number
of years the other reason why I think
this will prove to be controversial is
because I think the people have a
tendency to look at the idea of powerful
character and characters and to say
these are characters that can work
reality these are characters that have
extreme matter manipulation abilities or
something like that but with Vulcan his
uh basic abilities or his power lies in
the fact that he has not only immune to
virtually all forms of energy but that
he can manipulate almost all forms of
energy and absorb those energies and so
when you look at powerful characters and
Marvel Comics characters like magneto
for example who can manipulate the
electromagnetic spectrum this is a form
of energy and this is an energy that
that Vulcan can manipulate and so if
it's a form of energy it is something
that can be manipulated absorbed or else
simply discarded by Vulcan and it's for
this reason that I think he's one of the
more prominent characters because for
the most part
he is immune to pretty much any source
of power that anybody could channel at
him aside from physical strength so I
think that the choice of molecule man is
a character that is unexpected by all
except those who are the most avid comic
book readers and Marvel Comics and the
reason why is because unless you're an
avid reader of Marvel Comics molecule
man is most likely a character who is
unknown to you molecule man first
appeared in a Fantastic Four issue
number 20 and what we had seen during
this story is that somewhere along the
line he was working on a tonic radiation
on atomic energy but during his
experiment it had somehow gone awry and
when it did he had survived the
explosion and had also gained the
ability to manipulate molecules now
initially his ability to manipulate
molecules was confined to a relatively
small location and was on a very small
degree meaning that he was only able to
really manipulate things within his
immediate vicinity or within the planet
Earth itself and was only really able to
make subtle changes but with issue
number 11 of the secret Wars what we had
seen is that dr. doom had discovered the
molecule man had these subconscious
mental blocks in place now again this
wasn't something that molecule man had
intentionally put in place these were
here as a result of his uh self-doubt
and his self-loathing but once he was
able to gain confidence in himself and
his abilities he rose to being quite
possibly the most powerful character in
the Marvel Universe and is clearly the
most powerful earthbound character in
the Marvel Universe and the reason why I
say this is because after the events of
secret Wars where the Beyonder had a
more or less gone crazy and manipulated
not only our reality but other realities
the molecule man had gone back and fixed
it and so in effect what the molecule
man had done is manipulated the
molecules or manipulated multiple
realities as opposed to just our reality
with that being said I'm gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it and let me know your
list of your top 5 favorite or top five
most powerful earthbound characters in
the Marvel Comics I'm curious to see who
you guys come up with with that being
said I will see you guys in the next
video
you